[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان في هذه اللحظات عواصم
عديده في العالم تعيش على وقع احداث هامه
البدايه من العاصمه الاوكرانيه حيث تقول
القوات الجويه هناك انها تصدت لهجوم
صاروخي استهدف العاصمه فاذا ان الهجوم
الروسي تم بواسطه سته صواريخ فنجان وسته
صواريخ كاليبر ومسيرتين في وقت واحد
ومن العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم وهذه الصور
المباشره مع استمرار الاشتباكات في مناطق
مختلفه وقصف بطائرات الجيش السوداني
لمواقع لقوات الدعم السريع في الخرطوم
واندرمان
ومن العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن تريدون هذه
الصور المباشره في ظل توقعاتنا امريكيه
بعدم حدوث انفراجه في العلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه على خلفيه الزياره المرتقبه
لوزير الخارجيه الى الصين
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
تزامنا مع معارك تحتدم في دنيتك ومحيطها
شرقا اوكرانيا تعلن التصدي لقصف بالصواريخ
والمسيرات على كياب تصفه بالاكثر كثافه
وتتهم روسيا باستهداف العاصمه بالتزامن مع
زياره وفد وساطه افريقي
يقول انه لا تفاوض مع روسيا وهي تحتل
اراضيا اوكرانيه
يلوح بانشاء منطقه عازله داخل اوكرانيا
اذا استمرت الهجمات على المناطق الحدوديه
الروسيه
وبين زياره الى بيجين بقيت مؤجله منذ
فبراير الماضي لكن يدعو الى دبلوماسيه
تجنب البلدين المواجهه ويقول ان زيارته
تهدف لتكريس اتصالات قويه وتجنب الحسابات
الخاطئه استشار الامن القومي الامريكي لا
يتوقع انفراجه بعد الزياره وبجين تقول ان
الحوار مع واشنطن ممكن لكنه يجب ان يعالج
مخاوفها
تزامنا مع اشتباكات في شمال كردفان غارات
للجيش السوداني على مواقع للدعم السريع في
الخرطوم وام درمان
واشنطن تدين انتهاكات حقوق الانسان من
الطرفين وتتهم الدعم السريع ارتكاب فضاءات
[موسيقى]
مباحثات في باريس بين الرئيس الفرنسي
وولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
الاليزيه يقول ان الجانبين اكد الالتزام
بالامن والاستقرار الدولي والاقليمي وشدد
على ضروره انهاء الشهور السياسي المؤسسي
في لبنان والرياض تقول ان الرئيس الفرنسي
وولي العهد السعودي ناقش مستجدات الاحداث
الدوليه والاقليميه وتنسيق الجهود بشانها
ماساه جديده تسلط الضوء على ازمه
المهاجرين غير النظاميين فقد اثرنا معكم
القصه قبل قليل قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه حيث قضى عشرات الاشخاص في غرق
مركب يقل مئات المهاجرين غير النظاميين
قباله السواحل جنوب غرب اليونان المنظمه
الدوليه للهجره وفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين
رحبتا بفتح تحقيق في الحادث ودعت الى
اتخاذ اجراءات عاجله وحاسمه لمنع مزيد من
الماسي في البحر والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان
هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي برايكم كيف سيغير غرق عشرات من
طالبي اللجوم او بالاحرى من المهاجرين غير
النظاميين في الطاعات الدولي مع هذه
القضيه
16% توقعوا تغييرا ايجابيا في هذه
السياسات اما 64% فرجحوا مزيدا من تشدد
السلطات الاوروبيه في هذا الموضوع اما
عشرون بالمئه فتوقعوا ارتفاعا في نسق
قوارب المهاجرين غير النظاميين
هذا السؤال سيبقى كالعاده مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخوله صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا
على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيه
ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
احتمالات تعزز ارتفاع عدد ضحايا غرق مركب
المهاجرين غير النظاميين قباله اليونان
الى المئات والمنظمه الدوليه للهجره
والمفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين تدعواني الى
اجراءات عاجله وحاسمه
[موسيقى]
من جديد يعود مشهد القصف الى كييف حيث
قالت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه انها تصدت
لهجوم صاروخي روسيا استهدف العاصمه خلال
زياره لقاده افارقه ضمن مهمه وساطه واضافت
ان القوات الروسيه اطلقت سته صواريخ كنجال
وسته صواريخ كاليبر ومسيرتين في وقت واحد
واعلنت السلطات في كييف عن تضرر منزل ضمن
حدود مقاطعه كييف جراء هذا القصف
هذا وقد قالت نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكرانيه ان قوتي بلادها حققت تقدما
بنحو كيلومترين في ساحات المعارك التي
تقودها شرقا وتعمل على تثبيت مواقعها في
مقاله المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكرانيه ان الجيش الروسي بدا بالعوده
الى مواقع في خرسون كانت قد غمرتها المياه
سابقا بعد تفجير سد كاغوفكا
بدا الجيش الروسي والعوده الى المواقع
التي غمرتها المياه جراء تفجير محطتك
خوفكا ويكثف القصف الليله الماضيه كان
هناك حوالي 40 قصفا روسيا استهدف 8 بلدات
في منطقه فيرسون وللاسف هناك قتل وجرحى
تظهر حاليا مجموعات الهاون بالاضافه الى
القصف المدفعي ولكن هذا لا يمر ببساطه فقد
دمرت القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه خلال
الاربع والعشرين ساعه ماضيه ثلاث منشات
عسكريه
من جانبها قالت وزاره والدفاع الروسيه
انها احبطت خمس هجمات اوكرانيه على محور
دونيتسك وان الاوكرانيين يتكبدون خسائر
كبيره خلال هجماتهم على محور دنيا وجنوبها
في حين قالت سلطات دونيتك المواليه لروسيا
ان القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول اختراق
الدفاعات في محيط مدينه
وعرقلت تقدم الوحدات الروسيه ونقلت وكاله
على السلطات في ان ما وصفتها بقوات العدو
تحاول منع القوات الروسيه من تنفيذ عمليات
هجوميه واضافت ان القوات الروسيه تتخذ
الاجراءات اللازمه لمنع اي اختراق والحد
من القصف على بخمه
قال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين انه في
حال استمرت الهجمات على المناطق الحدوديه
الروسيه فان بلاده ستنظر في امكانيه انشاء
منطقه عازله داخل اوكرانيا وفي كلمته امام
منتدى سام اكد بوتين ان روسيا وضعت هدفا
يتمثل في نزع سلاح اوكرانيا مضيفا ان كيف
لن تستطيع ان تحارب طويلا بالاعتماد على
السلاح الغربي مشيرا الى انها ستستنفذ
قريبا جميع الاسلحه التي صنعتها
نرى جيدا الجهود الغربيه لالحاق هزيمه
استراتيجيه بروسيا انهم يقومون بكل شيء
لتحقيق ذلك لكننا بدورنا وضعنا مهمه محدده
ازاء ذلك وهي نزع سلاح اوكرانيا قريبا جدا
ستستنفذ اوكرانيا جميع الاسلحه التي
صنعتها وستعتمد فقط على الدعم العسكري
الغربي والاسلحه الغربيه لكنها لن تستطيع
ان تحارب طويلا بالاعتماد على السلاح
الغربي اما نحن فاننا نتقدم في صناعاتنا
العسكريه لقد ازداد انتاجنا عشره اضعاف
في هذه الاثناء قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي
ان الحلفاء في النيتو سيعززون الدعم
العسكريه لاوكرانيا لضمان تلبيه حاجاتها
الامنيه واكد ويسترن في مؤتمر الصحفي عقب
اجتماعا لوزراء دفاع النيتو في بروكسل ان
الحلفه لن ينجر الى الحرب التي يشنها
بوتين لكنه سيعزز دفاعاته
ما ساظل مركزا عليه هو ان نتاكد دائما
اننا نوفر المساعدات الامنيه التي تحتاجها
اوكرانيا في هذه الحرب من المهم ان نركز
مع شركائنا على هذا الجانب لدينا علاقات
ثنائيه مع اوكرانيا ونمضي في ذلك قدما
الاطراف والجهات التي تريد ان تبرم هذه
الاتفاقات تتحاور مع بعضها لكننا سنسعى
دائما للتاكد من حصول اوكرانيا على
الترتيبات الامنيه التي تحتاجها وهذه مهمه
ملحه بالنسبه الينا جميعا
سياسيا قال الرئيس الاوكراني
انه لن يكون هناك اي تفاوض مع روسيا مع
استمرار احتلالها لاراض اوكرانيه واضاف
خلال مؤتمر صحفي مع وفد القاده الافارقه
الذي يزور كييف ان بلاده تدعو الى سلام
حقيقي وانسحاب روسي من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وبالرغم من تعدد الوساطات منذ بدايه الحرب
لانها فشلت كلها في تحقيق اهدافها بجمع
المتحاربين حول طاوله التفاوض الجدي
اراد الاوكرانيون ان يبدا جدول زياره
الوفد الافريقي للوساطه من اجل انهاء
الحرب على وقع دوي في جرين على الاقل في
كييف وصل الوفد الذي يضم رؤساء ورؤساء
حكومات وقاده ست دول من افريقيا قلل الغرب
من فرص نجاح المبادره وصفا اياها بالاضعف
حكم مسبق مسيس بسبب موقفه من بريتوريا يضم
الوفد رئيس جنوب افريقيا سيرين الذي اختار
موقف الحياد والحوار منذ بدايه الحرب ورفض
ادانه نظام الرئيس بوتين عكس رغبه حلفاء
كييف تنص المبادره على انسحاب القوات
الروسيه ازاله الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه
من بيلاروسيا وتعليق مذكره التوقيف
الصادره من المحكمه الجنائيه بحق الرئيس
بوتين بما يسمح بتوفير البيئه المناسبه
لوقف اطلاق النار اسمع الرئيس فلودي
مرزيلنسكي ضيوف شروطك قبل اي حوار مع
موسكو
لن يكون هناك اي تفاوض مع روسيا وهي تستمر
في احتلال الاراضي الاوكرانيه لان ذلك
يعني استمرار الاحتلال وهدم تحاول روسيا
القيام به منذ سنوات وهي تحاول العوده الى
خدعها القديمه وخداع الجميع لكن روسيا لن
تستطيع خداع اي طرف خصوصا اوكرانيا ندعو
الى سلام حقيقي والى انسحاب الروسين حقيقي
من اراضي اوكرانيا المستقله
يامل الوسطاء الافارقه الحصول على تنازلات
من الكريملين قبل قمه روسيه افريقيه مقرره
الشهر المقبل
سيجري الوفد مباحثات السبت مع الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين في مدينه سانت
بيترسبورغ قبل وصولهم اكد الكريم ان
الازمه الاوكرانيه يمكن معالجتها بطرق
مختلفه وان الرئيس بوتين يدعم اي افكار
لانهاء النزاع
لكل طرف في الصراع شروطه التي تزداد
وتتغير كل ما اشتد الاقتتال وطال وكثره
التدخلات الخارجيه المعلنه والمستتره طرحت
منذ بدايه النزاع عده مبادرات لوقفه
ولكنها توقفت كلها عند نقطه البدايه قدمت
الصين وثقه مكونه من 12 بندا من اجل تسويه
سياسيه للازمه لم يرحب حلفاء اكياف بالعرض
نظرا للتقارب بين موسكو وبيجي خطه السلام
الاندونيسيه التي اسهب في تفاصيلها وزير
الدفاع بروباو سوبيانتو خلال منتدى لم
تعجبه منذ يومها الاول مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
من جهته يحاول الفاتيكون ايجاد تسويه
للوصول الى السلام يتولى المهمه
الذي زار اكياف خلال الشهر الجاري واجرى
محادثات مع الرئيس زلينسكي تعدد لم يقلص
من زمن الحرب ولا تداعياتها القاسيه على
اكثر من قاره وشعب لا يعرف اين تكمن
العقده في اصحاب المبادرات ام في المواقف
الغربيه المسبقه منهم ام في تشبث كل طرف
مباشر في الحرب بشروطه قبل اي تفاوض محتمل
ولانها حروب متعدده داخل حرب على الارض
الاوكرانيه دعوه السلام قد لا تسمع ولا
تستجاب ليس الان ولا غدا
وفي جانب اخر للصراع في اوكرانيا تعود الى
الواجهه مساله الارصده الروسيه المجمده
حول العالم حيث يتجه الكونجرس الى مناقشه
مشروع قانون يتيح مصادره اصول روسيه تابعه
للبنك المركزي بهدف استخدامها في تمويل
اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا وهي خطوه رحب بها
الرئيس الاوكراني فما هو حجم الاموال
الروسيه المجمده وما هي اجراءات مصادرتها
وابعاد هذه الخطوه
تقدر وزاره الماليه الروسيه حجم الاصول
المجمده من قبل الغرب بما يتراوح بين 300
مليار دولار و 300
مليارا اي قرابه نصف احتياطيات روسيا من
الذهب والنقد الاجنبي وسندات الدين يملك
البنك المركزي الروسي اكثر من 300 مليار
دولار من الاموال المجمده قانونيا تعود
ملكيه هذه الاصول للدوله الروسيه لكنها لا
تستطيع التصرف بها بسبب العقوبات وتقدر
الاموال الخاصه بمواطنين يحملون الجنسيه
الروسيه بنحو 30 مليار دولار تصنف هذه
الاموال في فئه الملكيه الفرديه الخاصه
خبراء في القانون يؤكدون وجود اختلاف جذري
بين تجميد الاصول ومصادرتها فالتجميد خطوه
تحتمل ان تكون قانونيه اما المناظره
فتحتاج الى قوانين لحالات خاصه لا يمكن
تعميمها ورغم جهود مشرعين امريكيين لوضع
قوانين تمكن الرئيس من استخدام الاموال
الروسيه المجمده الا ان القوانين النافذه
واضحه يمنح قانون السلطه الطوارئ
الاقتصاديه الدوليه رئيس الولايات المتحده
السلطه كي يجمد الاصول المملوكه لاجانب
بما في ذلك ممتلكات دول اجنبيه
والتجميد في هذه الحاله يهدف الى تدمير
القيمه الاقتصاديه للاصول بتجريم محاوله
التعامل بها او الحصول على منافع منها لكن
التجميد في هذه الحاله لا يعني تغيير
ملكيه تلك الاصول وبحسب خبراء هناك
استثناء نادر جدا في هذا القانون يمنح
الرئيس الحق في مصادره الممتلكات الاجنبيه
والتصرف بها
والاستثناء يكون بترقب او وقوع اعمال
عدائيه من قبل دوله اجنبيه او مواطنين
اجانب فما هي المشاكل القانونيه التي تعوق
المصادره
يميز خبراء القانون بين الاصول الخاصه
التي جمدتها حكومات غربيه وبين ممتلكات
الدوله مثل احتياطيات العملات الاجنبيه
للبنك المركزي الروسي في حاله الاصول
الخاصه تعني الضمانات القانونيه انه لا
يسمح للدول الغربيه بمصادرتها الا في حال
اثبات انها عائدات من انشطه اجراميه
وبالتالي فان مصادرتها تشكل تعديا على
الحقوق القانونيه وحقوق الانسان الاساسيه
لصعوبه اثبات الجرم اما الاصول العامه
للدول فعاده ما ترتبط باتفاقيات استثمار
ثنائيه او دوليه وبالتالي فان مصادرتها قد
تعرض الدول المعنيه لمطالبات قانونيه في
محاكم دوليه
من جهه اخرى تطرح اصول الدول كاحتياطيات
البنك المركزي مشاكل مختلفه لكنها شائكه
ايضا لانها مغطاه بما تسمى الحصانه
السياديه وهي تفاهم يقضي بان لا تستولي
دوله على ممتلكات دوله اخرى اما روسيا
فتبدو مستعده للرد في حال المصادره اذ وقع
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين مرسوما يقضي بوضع
الاصول الاجنبيه في روسيا تحت السيطره
المؤقته للدوله او تحت ادارتها مؤقتا اذا
تمت مصادره اصول روسيه في الخارج
[موسيقى]
بعد الان من واشنطن دولار وهو الدبلوماسيه
الامريكيه السابق ومدير شؤون روسيا في
معهد السلامه الامريكي ومن موسكو اندروف
نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه السابقه اهلا
بضيفين نبدا من واشنطن والسيد جنس هل فعلا
يمكن ان يمضي المشرع الامريكي في مصادره
الاموال الروسيه
بامكانهم ذلك في الحقيقه لكن علينا ان
نتذكر حجم هذه المشكله ما نتحدث عنه هو
حساب كميه الاضرار التي طبعا الاضرار لا
يستهان بها والتي تسببتها الحرب العدوانيه
الروسيه ثم علينا ان نميز بان اصول
موجودات الدوله مثل البنك المركزي وبين
تلك التي تسمى
بالخاصه او الاصول الخاصه العائده لافراد
كلها ومعظمها باتا مجمدا لكن نحتاج الى
التشريعات
للمصادره في النهايه على الروس ان يدفعوا
مقابل ما تسببوا به من اضرار لكن علينا ان
نعثر على الاطر القانونيه اللازمه لعمل
ذلك وفعلا الاطر القانونيه هي المشكله هل
هل سيكون هذا الامر يسيرا
اعتقد ان العمليه معقده لكن هناك مسار
يمكن اللجوء الى جزء من المشكله ان
الاموال والارصده ليست في الوقت المتحده
بل هي في عده بلدان غربيه لاننا سامحنا
بالنشاط الاجرامي الروسي على مدى عقدين
والاوليغار الروس بان ينقل اموالهم الى
الغرب اذا التعامل مع والتعاون مع البلدان
مهم لكن تنفيذ هذه الامور ليس سهلا لكن من
خلال التعاون يمكن ان نحل ذلك وانا ارحب
بجهود الولايات المتحده للبدء بعمل ذلك
السيد في موسكو هل
تتوقعون ان تسير الامور الى هذه الدرجه في
العلاقه مع واشنطن
متعلقا بواسطه فقط لكن مع عدد من البلدان
الاخرى خاصه البلدان المنضويه تحت لواء
الاتحاد الاوروبي نعم لا توجد هناك
تشريعات مباشره تسمح بذلك لكن في الولايات
المتحده وفي الاتحاد الاوروبي هناك حرب
قانونيه ان صحت التسميه لتمكين ذلك
المساله لا تتعلق
بهذه البلدان فحسب كندا مثلا
وصادرت الطائره شحن هي الانتنوف 124
الاكبر من نوعها في العالم
وكجزء من مصادره الوصول الروسيه تريد
تسليمها لاوكرانيا اذا الامر لا يتعلق
بالمال فقط لذا بالنسبه لروسيا هذا سيشكل
تحديا كبيرا
فقط موجودات البنك المركزي تفوق 300 مليار
دولار وهي اكثر او نحو نصف الاحتياطي من
العمله الاجنبيه لروسيا والان روسيا تهتم
اهتماما خاصا وتعتبر هذه الخطوات خطوات
منافيه للقانون لكن لو ان التشريعات تم
تغييرها في الولايات المتحده اوروبا سيكون
صعبا على روسيا ان تدافع عن موقفها سيدي
هو ليس فقط تحديا هو هو كارثي تقريبا اذا
حصل هذا الامر هل هل السلطات في موسكو
يمكن ان تراجع بعض حساباتها في موضوع
اوكرانيا في ضوء مثل هذا الاحتمال
في هذه المرحله الاجابه هي لا وهم يعلمون
ذلك واعتقدوا ان السلطات الروسيه معنيه
بالاجراءات المضاده مثل مصادره موجودات
اصول الشركات الغربيه التي مازال بعضها
موجودا في روسيا او بعض اصولها الماديه
هذا يمكن ان يكون جبهه اخرى في الحرب جبهه
ماليه في الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا تدخل
فيها البلدان الغربيه قبل قليل سيد جونسون
في واشنطن اشرت الى الاشكالات القانونيه
ابرز اشكال قانوني ربما وان واشنطن لا
يمكنها مبدئيا ان تصادر اموال الا اذا
كانت من دوله
تتوقع منها عملا عدائيا معينا هذه الحاله
غير موجوده مع روسيا ما العمل
غيرت التشريعات المتحده
والغرب تؤمن بحقوق الملكيه لكن هناك
امكانيه لتغيير الاجراءات من خلال تغيير
التشريعات وانا اتوقع من الكونغرس واتوقع
في واشنطن في اماكن اخرى ان تبذل جهود
مستفيضه في هذا المجال لان الوضع طبعا في
روسيا لا يصير لصالح
المؤسسه العسكريه الروسيه وهم في النهايه
قد يحتاجون الى الدخول في مصالحه وعمليه
تسويه سياسيه وعند ذاك ستاتي مساله حساب
الاضرار التي تسببت بها روسيا وروسيا
عليها ان تدفع لان كلفه الحرب التي
بها الرسل هي حرب كارثيه بمعنى الكلمه
وسيكون صعبا لقياس كل كلف الحرب على
الاصعده الاقتصاديه والانسانيه
وايضا
كل هذه الامور ينبغي ان تؤخذ الحسبان وسوف
تؤخذ بالحسبان وسوف نستغرق وقتا لحل كل
الحيثيات القانونيه لكن سيتم في النهايه
عمل ذلك من الناحيه القانونيه وجعل روسيا
تدفع ما تسببت به شكرا جزيلا لك دون الجنس
من واشنطن شكرا جزيلا ايضا لضيفنا من
موسكو اندرو فيدروف
وفي ملفي حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اليوم
سيكون لنا حديث معمق وموسع عن المنطقه
العازله التي لوح الرئيس الروسي بانشائها
داخل اوكرانيا في حال استمرت الهجمات على
المناطق الحدوديه لبلاده
[موسيقى]
في سياق التوتر الامريكيه الصينيه قال
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان زيارته
المرتقبه الى الصين تهدف الى اقامه
اتصالات قويه ومفتوحه لتمكين البلدين من
اداره العلاقات بمسؤوليه وانه سيسعى خلال
هذه الزياره لاكتشاف احتمالات التعاون في
تحديات متعدده واضاف بلانكن خلال مؤتمن
صحفي مع نظيره السنغافوري في واشنطن ان
المنافسه المحتدمه مع الصين تتطلب
دبلوماسيه مستدامه لضمان الا تتحول الى
مواجهه او صراع
وكان مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي قال ان
الولايات المتحده لا تتوقع حدوثا انفراجه
في علاقتهم مع الصين بعد زياره بلنكن
واضاف سولفين في بيان ان زياره رئيس
الوزراء الهندي لو واشنطن الاسبوع المقبل
تكتسي اهميه اكثر في هذا الاطار من زياره
بلنكن الى الصين
وردا على موقف مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الصينيه
ان باب الحوار مع واشنطن مفتوح الاتصالات
بين بلاده والولايات المتحده لم تنقطع
مشددا على ضروره الا يضر او الا يتسبب اي
طرف باضرار
للطرف الاخر
باب الحوار والتواصل في الصين مفتوح على
مصراعيه والاتصال بين البلدين لم ينقطع
يجب ان يعالج التواصل مخاوف الطرفين ويجب
ان تكون له اثار عمليه لحل المشكلات دون
الاضرار بمصالح الطرف الاخر او قول شيء
وفعل شيء اخر
قال الرئيس الصيني جيشين بنج ان الولايات
المتحده والصين يمكنهم التعاون لصالح
البلدين واوضح الرئيس الصيني خلال
الاجتماع اليوم الجمعه مع بيل جيتس المؤسس
المشاركه في شركه مايكروسوفت ان العلاقات
الصينيه الامريكيه تقع على عاتق الشعب
ولذلك ينبغي الا تكون هناك انشطه متعدده
تعود بالنفع على البلدين والشعبين
والبشريه باكملها ولم يذكر الرئيس الصيني
اي تفاصيل اخرى لكنه اكد على الفوائد
المحتمله للتعاون الذي عرقلته خلافات بشان
حقوق الانسان وتايوان والامن والتكنولوجيا
نقلت صحيفه عن مصادر مطلعه ان اداره
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن عدت منذ شهر
امرا تنفيذيا لتقييد الاستثمار لدى
منافسين من بينهم الصين كما نقلت شبكه ام
بي سي عن مسئولينا امريكيين رفيعي المستوى
ان بيضا كان يعتزم الاتصال بنظيره الصيني
بعد اسقاط منطاد التجسس واضاف المسؤولون
بحسب ام بي سي دائما ان مستشاري مستشاري
الامن القومي طلبوا من بايدن تخفيض مستوى
الاتصال مع الصين
[موسيقى]
هلا مراسل الجزيره ان اصوات اسلحه ثقيله
سمعت في وسط وجنوب الخرطوم تزامنا مع
تحليقا لمقاتلات حربيه في اجواء العاصمه
السودانيه وانا المقاتلات قصفت مواقع
لقوات الدعم السريع في مواقع عده في
الخرطوم وام درمان وافاد مراسلنا بوقوع
اشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع في الابيض عاصمه ولايه شمال كردفان
بينما استمرت الاشتباكات في بلده اديكون
بولايه غرب دارفور المحاذيه للحدود مع
مدينه ادريس التشاديه وقالت الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان الفظائع في دارفور تقوم بها
في المقام الاول قوات الدعم السريع
وابليشيات تابعه لها ومع ذلك فان كلا
الجانبين مسؤول عن الانتهاكات
يوم دام اخر في حرب الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع التي تختلط اوراقها او تكاد
استمر الحال في الخرطوم على ذات وتيرته
اليوميه وتحدث مراسل الجزيره عن اصوات
اسلحه ثقيله سمعت في وسط وجنوب المدينه
وطائرات حربيه قصفت مواقع لقوات الدعم
السريع في المدينه الرياضيه وارض
المعسكرات جنوبي الخرطوم ومناطق في ام
درمان في هذه الاثناء لا تزال احداث ولايه
غرب دارفور الداميه تسيطر على تطورات
الاحداث وتمددت اشتباكات المسلحين
الموالين لوال الولايه الذي قتل اخيرا
وقوات الدعم السريع والمليشيات المؤيده
لها الى بلده اديكون المحاذيه لحدود
الولايه مع مدينه ادريساديه
الخارجيه الامريكيه دانت ما وصفته
بالانتهاكات المستمره لحقوق الانسان
والعنف المروع في المنطقه ودعت الجيش
والدعم السريع بوقف القتال في دارفور
والسيطره على قواتهما ومحاسبه المسؤولين
عن الانتهاكات واشار بيان الوزاره في هذا
الشان الى التقارير عن انتشار العنف
الجنسي والقتل على اساس عرقي في غرب
دارفور الذي تمارسه قوات الدعم السريع
والميليشيات المتحالفه معها وانها
المسؤوله عن الفضائع الجاريه اخيرا لكن
البيان راى ايضا ان الجيش مسؤول معها عن
الانتهاكات واتهم البيان الجيش السوداني
بالاخفاق في حمايه المدنيين في دارفور في
هذه الاثناء قالت الامم المتحده ان
الاوضاع في دارفور تتجه بسرعه نحو كارثه
انسانيه ودعا مارتن جريفيث وكيل الامين
العام للمنظمه الدوليه للشؤون الانسانيه
الى تحرك دولي عاجل لتدارك الامر وضمان
نقل الامدادات العاجله للاقليم حيث يحتاج
اليها نحو تسعه ملايين شخص لكن الصعوبات
تكتنف التلبيه السريعه لهذه الحاجه في ظل
انسحاب العاملين في مجال الاغاثه من
المنطقه واستمرار الحرب بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع من جهه واستمرار الصراع
القبلي القديم المتجدد في المنطقه من جهات
اخرى
وقبل الحصاد كنا قد التقينا بالسيده
كليمونتين لكوتيا سلمي المنسقه الدوليه
الامميه للامم المتحده لشؤون الانسانيه في
السودان سالناها اولا عن تقييم الوضع
الانساني الحاليه في السودان بشكل عام
الوضع في السودان حاليا سيء فنحن ندخل في
الشهر الثالث من النزاع والوضع يمكن ان
يصبح كارثيا بسرعه لدينا اكثر من 24 مليون
شخص بحاجه ماسه الى المساعدات الانسانيه
مليونان منهم من النازحين داخل وخارج
البلاد وهناك مئات الاشخاص الذين قتلوا او
اصيبوا بجروح بالغه الوضع في دارفور حرج
للغايه وقد يتحول الى كارثي في اقرب وقت
عندما تقولين قد يتحول الى كارثه ما
المقصود تحديدا
اقصد بذلك اننا بحاجه الى ايصال المساعدات
في اسرع وقت ممكن حتى الان وصلنا الى
مليون وثمانمائه الف شخص ممن قدمنا لهم
خدمات صحيه وغذائيه لكن الوضع في دارفور
يتطلب تداخلا عاجلا ونحتاج الى نقل
الموارد الموجوده داخل البلد الى دارفور
باسرع وقت الالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار
المؤقت ساعدنا في نقل بعض المواد بدعم من
السلطات المحليه لكن لدينا اكثر من ثمانيه
ملايين شخص في دارفور في امس الحاجه الى
المساعده التقارير تفيد ان هناك حالات قتل
وان الناس بحاجه الى المواد الطبيه
والغذائيه والعلاج
افهم من كلامك سيدتي بان الوضع في دارفور
قد يكون اسوا بكثير من باقي مناطق السودان
ما الفرق تحديدا الذي يجعل من دارفور اسوا
بكثير
نحن قادرون على الوصول الى معظم انحاء
البلاد لكننا غير قادرين على الوصول الى
الخرطوم نعمل مع مؤسسات محليه واستطعنا
ايصال بعض المساعدات كما ساهمت بعض
المؤسسات الدوليه مثل منظمه الغذاء
العالميه في تقديم المساعده لكن الخرطوم
لم نستطع الوصول اليها بسبب شده القتال
نحتاج الى رفع بعض العراقيل البيروقراطيه
وادخال الموظفين وتسهيل حركه الشاحنات
الموجوده داخل البلاد لتصل الى دارفور
ونحملها بالمواد الطبيه والغذائيه لدينا
فرصه ضئيله لنقل الحبوب لان موسم الح
والزراعه يقترب بسرعه واذا استطعنا نقل
الحبوب سيساعد هذا الامر المزارعين على
زرعها ولن يخسروا هذا الموسم نحتاج الى
سمات دخول للعاملين لدينا وتسهيلات على
الطرق وجهنا احيانا تاخيرات وهذا يعرقل
مساعينا اذا استطعنا الحصول على رخص مرور
وتمكنت شاحناتنا من الحركه ووصلت الى
السلطات المعنيه والهيئات المحليه فذلك
سيساعدنا على نقل هذه المواد بشكل كبير
من يتحمل مسؤوليه كل هذه العراقيل التي
تشيرنا اليها الان
كما قلت الى سمات دخول الى البلاد نحتاج
ان نضمن ان الذين يسيطرون على الطرق سوف
يمنحون طواقمنا ضمانات لتتمكن شاحناتنا من
الحركه بامان وتستطيع الوصول الى السكان
لدينا شبكات على الارض وبعض الخزين الذي
جمعناه واستطعنا ايصال بعض المؤنث لكن كان
هناك عمليات نهب للمواد الانسانيه وهذا
يرفع من كلفه قدرتنا على ايصال المساعدات
الى من هم بحاجه ماسه اليها
هل تتهمون طرفا معينا بالوقوف وراء هذا
النهب للمستودعات
ليست لدي معلومات دقيقه عن من هو المسؤول
عن النهب نعلم ان النهب قد تم واننا خسرنا
من ارصدتنا ومن مخزونات المستودعات لكن
المهم ان ننقل ما تبقى لدينا وان نركز على
ايصال هذه المواد باسرع وقت ممكن السلامه
والامن هما امران حيويان للسكان وللمنظمات
الاغاثيه كي تستطيع ايصال هذه المساعدات
شكرا لك يا سيدتي
منسقه الامم المتحده لشؤون الانسانيه في
السودان شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
طلب بيان لرئاسه الفرنسيه ان الرئيس
ايمانيويل ماكرون وولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان اكد الالتزام بالامن
والاستقرار في الشرق الادنى والشرق الاوسط
واورد البيان انما كراون واولي العهد
السعودي اعرب خلال لقائهما في قصر
الاليزيه عن رغبتهما بمواصله جهود تخفيف
التوترات بشكل دائم كما قال بيان الاليزي
ان الرئيس الفرنسي جدد لولي العهد السعودي
التزام باريس بامن السعوديه واستقرارها
وان مكروه للعهد السعودي اكد على ضروره
انهاء الشهور السياسيه المؤسسي في لبنان
هذا وقد ذكرت وكاله الانباء السعوديه ان
ولي العهد السعودي محمد بن سلمان بحث في
باريس مع الرئيس الفرنسي
مستجدات الاحداث الدوليه والاقليميه
وتنسيق الجهود المبذوله المشتركه بشانها
واستعرض الجانبان العلاقات التاريخيه
والاستراتيجيه بين بلديهما وسبل تطويرها
في جميع المجالات بما يخدم مصالح البلدين
معنا من جده الدكتور خالد بطرفي
الاكاديميه والمحلل السياسي ومن باريس
بيير بيرتيلو الباحث في المعهد الاوروبي
للاستشراف والامن اهلا بضيفينا نبدا
بالدكتور بطره في في كل القضايا التي
بحثت في باريس برايك ما الابرز
انا اعتقد ان الابرز هو دور المملكه
المرتقب في الوساطه بين روسيا واوكرانيا
هذا الدور الذي طلب من السعوديه في اكثر
من مناسبه وكانت السعوديه تبدي يعني
قبولها بشرط ان يقبل الطرفان الان يبدو
وخاصه بعد المكالمه الطويله مع بوتين وولي
العهد السعودي قبل ايام
ان هناك وايضا زياره الرئيس الاوكراني
ولقائه
بسموه العهد ان هناك اجواء مناسبه
لدور سعودي مرتقب ومقبول من الجميع سواء
معسكر الشرقي او الغربي او من طرفي الصراع
وهل تعتقد دكتور باتر في ان هذا الامر
منسق ايضا مع واشنطن في نفس الوقت
بالتاكيد واشنطن هي طرق رئيسي في ذلك
ولا ننسى ان وزير الخارجيه
كان موجود ايضا في السعوديه والتقى بسمه
ولي العهد وقبل ذلك كان مستشار الامن
القومي
وهناك لقاءات اخرى مع مسؤولين امريكان
سواء مع السعوديه او مع دول الخليج انا
اعتقد ان الامر منسق بين جميع الاطراف في
هذه الحاله سيدبرتلوا في في باريس هل تامل
فرنسا من ان السعوديه بامكانها ان تفعل
فيما فشل فيه اخرون في الملف الاوكراني
تحديدا
فرنسا تامل ذلك لان فرنسا لا تودي ان ترى
استمرارا بهذا النزاع حيث ان الموقف
الفرنسي يقول انه اذا ما استمرت الحرب على
ما هي عليه الموقف الفرنسي يصبح الضعف
والموقف الاوروبي يصبح اضعف الان المساله
هي ان روسيا لا تصغي الى فرنسا روسيا لا
تصغي الى فرنسا ورئيس ماكرون غير في
سياسته التي كان قد اعتمدها في البدايه
وايضا كان هناك تبادلات اعلن اعلنها على
التلفزيون الفرنسي بالنسبه الى محادثاته
مع روسيا وهذا ادى الى زعزعه الثقه
وبالتالي البلدان التي تثق بها فرنسا
محدوده بالنسبه الى دور الوساطه طبعا
تركيا ادت دورا ولكنها لا تحظى بثقه فر من
يتبقى المملكه العربيه السعوديه على وجه
الخصوص ونحن نعرف ان هناك علاقات نسجت مع
ولي العهد السعودي محمد بن سلمان بينه
وبين الرئيس الفرنسي هي علاقه ايجابيه هما
من نفس الجيل
ويوداني ان يحدثا البلدين للتحضيري
للمستقبل وبالتالي المملكه العربيه
السعوديه يمكنها ان تؤدي دور الوساطه في
الملف الاوكراني ولقد استضافت
اثناء القمه العربيه في جده وكانت مفاجاه
وفرنسا هي البلد الذي دفع
باتجاه استقبال زينينسكي في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وبالتالي هناك لعبه نرى
ما هي الان هذه مهمه بالنسبه الى فرنسا
اعاده نسج الاتصال مع روسيا ولكن عبر بلد
مقرب من فرنسا بالمقارنه مع
تركيا او الصين التي حاولت كذلك ان تؤدي
هذا الدور في الماضي اذا تركنا الملف
الاوكراني سيد بترفي هناك اشاره الى لبنان
وما سمي بالفراغ المؤسسي هناك فرنسا لها
حلفائها في لبنان وكذلك السعوديه ما الذي
يمكن ان يفعل في هذا الاتجاه
فرنسا لها علاقه جيده مع ثنائي الشيعي
وايران السعوديه الان على توافق مع ايران
واعتقد ان الملف اللبناني طرح في
المباحثات مع السعوديه
مع سوريا ايضا علاقات جيده انا اعتقد
الوقت الوقت الان افضل من اي وقت مضى لان
تحل هذه المشكله بالتوافق مع الاطراف
المعنيه هناك اللجنه الخماسيه وتضم ايضا
بالاضافه لهذين البلدين قطر ومصر
والولايات المتحده وانا اعتقد ان الجميع
يتكلمون بلغه واحده على
اللبنانيين ان يعجلوا بانتخاب رئيس ورئيس
حكومه لتبدا تنفيذ الاصلاحات التي يطالب
بها المجتمع الدولي
والمنظمات الدوليه كصندوق النقد الدولي
البنك الدولي
وتصحيح المسار الذي تسير اليه او تنزلق
اليه البلد الى الهاويه
فالجميع كل من يهتم لامر لبنان لابد ان
يشغلوا هذا الامر وهذه فرصه
للطرفين الاكثر تاثيرا في لبنان
السعوديه وفرنسا ان يتدارسا هذا الوضع وان
يسعى كلا من جانبه
وبعلاقاته الى تصحيح المسار وتصويب
الاوضاع الراهنه اذا بهذا المعنى سيد
برتلوه هل هل نتوقع انفراج ما في موضوع
الرئاسه اللبنانيه على الاقل
نحن نعرف ان هناك فراغا دستوريا في لبنان
ولبنان يفتقر الى الرئيس وهو امرا سلبي
بالنسبه الى لبنان الذي هو بامش الحاجه
الى الاستقرار طبعا هناك عدد من العوامل
المؤثره ايران الولايات المتحده السعوديه
وفرنسا لاسباب تاريخيه لانها كانت وراء
ولاده لبنان الجديد وبالتالي هناك عدد من
الفرقاء الذين لا يودون ان يفتحوا حوارا
مع ايران ونفس الشيء بالنسبه الى الاحزاب
التابعه لايران لا تود ان تفتح حديثا مع
واشنطن النقطه الايجابيه هي ان فرنسا
تتحدث مع الجميع ولديها اتصالات مع كل
الفرقاء اللبنانيين والامر السيان بالنسبه
الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه وخصوص بعد
التقارب الذي حصل مؤخرا مع ايران وبالتالي
واشنطن لا يمكنها ان تؤدي نفس الدور الذي
باستطاعه السعوديه او فرنسا ان تؤدي اياه
هذه من بين اللقاءات المهمه واذا ما تم
التوافق على هذا المستوى جزء من المشكله
يحل ولربما نرى اخر هذا النفق ولكن يجب
العمل على مرشح توافقي لاننا راينا ان
جلسه انتخاب رئيس التي جرت على مستوى
البرلمان لم تسمح بتوصل الى انتخابي رئيس
هناك اصوات متقاربه بين المرشحين
الرئيسيين شكرا لضيفينا من باريس بيير
بيرتولو والدكتور خالد بطرفي من جده
[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل الجزيره بان السلطات اليونانيه
رصدت سفينه تقل مهاجرين غير نظاميين قباله
ساحل بيلوس جنوبا باتجاه المياه الايطاليه
ويتوافد العشرات من اقارب ضحايا حادث غرق
سفينه كانت تقل المئات من المهاجرين غير
النظاميين الى مدينه كلماتا اليونانيه في
محاوله للحصول على اي معلومات عن مصير
ذويهم هذا وقد طلبت كل من المنظمات
الدوليه للهجره ومفوضيه الامم المتحده
لشؤون اللاجئين باجراءات عاجله وحاسمه
لوضع حدا لهذا النوع من الماسي ورحبت
بالتزام اليونان بالتحقيق في ملابسات
الحادث
بطيئه تمر ساعات في مدينه كلمات اليونانيه
حيث يتوافد من قاده حظه العاثر الى البحث
عن اخ مفقود او زوجه غائبه او جار انقطعت
اخباره الى جانب رفاقه المنكوبين يبحث
خالد اللاجئ السوري عن اخ ضاعت اخباره بعد
غرق سفينه يقال انها كانت تقل ازيد من سبع
مئه لاجئ بالنسبه لاهالي المفقودين
المفقود ميت
المفروض ميت وتعتيم كامل
ما حدا عم يساعدنا منظمات يونانيه موجوده
منظمات هولنديه المانيه ما حدا عم يساعدنا
الصحافه الموجوده نهائيا السلطات
اليونانيه كامل
[موسيقى]
الناجين لكنهم رغم ذلك يؤكدون ان هذه
الفاجعه افرزت غصه في قلوبهم لن تختفي
قريبا
لكم ان تتصوروا شعورنا ونحن نرى كيف تحول
بحر ايجا الى مقبره حزن وياس لان ما يحدث
غير انساني الى ان تتكشف كل تفاصيل هذا
الحادث تقول سلطات اليونانيه ان امل
العثور على الناجين والمفقودين بات ضئيلا
فالحادث وقع في واحده من اعمق مناطق
المتوسط فاتحا للنقاشه حول نجاعه سياسه
الهجره الاوروبيه التي لا هي اوقفت تدفق
اللاجئين ولا هي نجحت في تفادي مثل هذه
الكوارث اي بنازوبير الجزيره من مدينه
كلماتا جنوبي اليونان
[موسيقى]
بالعوده الى تلميح الرئيس الروسي بانشاء
منطقه عازله داخل اوكرانيا في حال استمرت
الهجمات على مناطق الروسيه هنا نلقي نظره
اقرب على ما يجري سواء على الحدود او في
العمق الروسي اكثر المقاطعات الروسيه
تضررا هي
تقابلها خركيف الاوكرانيه وهي تتعرض اما
للقصف او للتسلل من قبل مجموعات تقول انها
روسيه معارضه لسياسه موسكو لتشعل بعض
النقاط في المقاطعه وتاخذ احيانا بعض
الرهان ليست بالورود وحدها هناك ايضا كورس
كالمجاوره وبريان ايضا تتعرضان ايضا
للاستهداف بقصف او هجمات
لتوغل بريا هناك كذلك تعرض تعرضت
وهي غربيه البلاد تعرضت لهجوم ممن وصفتهم
موسكو بالمخربين الاوكرانيين على محطتين
نوويتين استهدف هجوم سيارتين ملغمتين محطه
لتكرير النفط في منطقه بيسكوف وهي التي
تمد خط دروجبا الضخم الذي ينقل النفط
الخام من سيبيريا الى اوروبا كما تعرض
مطران عسكريان للاستهداف في منطقه ريازان
وساراتوف على بعد مئات الكيلومترات من
ساحه المعركه في اوكرانيا العاصمه الروسيه
نفسها موسكو تعرضت هي الاخرى لاكثر من مره
لهجوم بطائرات مسيره وهي هجمات تنفيك
دائما المسؤوليه عنها هذه التصريحات من
جانب بوتين تثير اسئله عده بشان امكانيه
فردي منطقه عازله في اراض تحتلها روسيا
بالفعل داخل اوكرانيا ولا تسيطر عليها
بالكامل بحكم التطورات الميدانيه لكن
لنعرف اولا ما هي المناطق العازله التي
تسمى احيانا بالامنه
هي مساحه في بلد ما يحددها الامم المتحده
من اجل توفير الحمايه للسكان المدنيين
ويكون ذلك في حالات الحروب والصراعات
الداخليه كما تقام مثل هذه المناطق على
حدود دولتين متجاورتين يوجد بينهما نزاع
او خلاف من الناحيه القانونيه يقع جزء من
المنطقه العازله على اراضي الدوله الاولى
الجزء الاخر على اراضي الدوله الثانيه ومن
الضروري ان يتوفر حظر جوي لحمايه هذه
المنطقه العازله وذلك لا يتحقق الا
بموافقه من مجلس الامن الدولي متابعه لهذا
الموضوع معنا من عمان لواء فايزه الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا
بك حضره اللواء
هل من الممكن عمليا انشاء منطقه عازله بين
روسيا واوكرانيا في ظل المعطيات التي
نعرفها جميعا
يعني هناك ثلاثه تصريحات من ثلاثه مسؤولين
اولا الرئيس الاسبق اعتبر ان المنطقه
العازل يجب ان تكون الحدود البولنديه اي
بمعنى اخر ان اوكرانيا كامله يجب ان تكون
منطقه عازله احد اعضاء الدوما في هذا
اليوم صرح بان عمق المنطقه العاجل يجب ان
يكون ثلاث مئه كيلو متر وهذا سيكون الى
غرب نهر الدنيا
والتصريح الرئيس بوتين مرتبط بمدايات
الاسلحه
وبالتالي يعني هناك ثلاثه تصريحات بثلاثه
ابعاد الجغرافيه من منظور الواقع اعتقد ان
الوقت الان لا يمكن روسيا من انشاء منطقه
عازله وفقا للمفهوم الروسي وليس لمفهوم
القانون الدولي لماذا لان القوات الروسيه
هي الان المدافعه نعم هي تهاجم في بعض
المناطق لكن القوات المتعرضه هي الق
الاوكرانيه وهي تصرح صراحه على الصعيد
العسكري والسياسي انها تسعى لاستعاده
الاراضي الاوكراني المحتله اذا من منظور
واقعي لا تملك روسيا القدره حاليا على
ترجمه هذه التصريحات الى واقع ملموس هل
هناك ايضا تناقض بين دعوه موسكو لمنطقه
عازله ورغبتها الدائمه في اوكرانيا منزوعه
السلاح لان المساله ايضا بها بعض التناقض
يا سيدي يعني التصريحات متباينه وانت اشرت
يعني كانت التصريحات ليست تصريح الاول
للرئيس بوتين حول مجازا تعريف المنطقه
العازله او ما يقصده بالمنطقه العازله او
المنطقه الفاصله حسب التعريف القانوني لكن
الان هو تحدث في هذا اليوم
من ضمن الشروط السته التي وضعت وتحدث عنها
خلال ال 48 ساعه الماضيه هو يتحدث عن
منسوعه السلاح اليوم اشاره صراحه الى انها
لم تعد تملك الكثير من الاسلحه الذاتيه
ذات من خلال التصنيع وانما ما تملكه من
الاسلحه التي تاتي بها تاتيها من الغرب
وهو صرح ان احد البنود السته من وجهه نظره
لانهاء الصراع القائم توقف امداد السلاح
الغربي اي بمعنى اخر ان تكون اوكرانيا
محايده اوكرانيا خارج النيتو اوكرانيا
منزوعه السلاح اوكرانيا بدون الكتائب
النازيه ولكن ايضا
السيد اللواء اي اي منطقه عازله تاتي
بترتيب دولي
بقرار من مجلس الامن عاده هذه مساله تكون
مستحيله الان في ظل احتلال روسي للزامل من
اوكرانيا
سيدي انا قلت لك المنطقه العازله من منظور
روسي وليس من منظور التعريف الدولي عندما
نتحدث عن المنطقه العازله اما تكون داخل
حدود الدوله او تكون بين دولتين داخل
الحدود الدوله في حاله الصراع الداخلي كما
نشا في سوريا والمطالبه التركيه بانشاء
منطقه عاليه منطقه عازله عندما تكون بين
دولتين كما هو بين كوريا الشماليه وكوريا
الجنوبيه او بين العراق والكويت بعد غزو
بعد انسحاب العراق وحرب
1991 في الواقع الحالي اذا تحدثنا وفقا
لمفهوم القانون التعريف القانون الدولي
للمنطقه العازله يجب ان تكون جزء من اراضي
روسيا وجزء من اراضي اوكرانيا علما ان
الاراضي التي تحتلها روسيا لا تعترف الامم
المتحده
اراضي روسيه اذا يجب ان تكون جزء من
الجغرافيا الروسيه المعترف بها دوليا شكرا
لك
من عمان وبهذا نصل الى نهايه الحصاد هذه
الليله في امان الله
[موسيقى]